la primera latina que iba a ser
ejecutada en texas se salvó de la
inyección letal al menos por ahora el
tribunal de apelaciones de delitos
penales suspendió la ejecución de
melissa lúcio la sentencia de muerte de
esta estadounidense de origen mexicano
estaba programada para el próximo
miércoles
[Música]
pasar de que en dos o tres días el
estado de texas la iba a matar a que
ahora esto suceda es una gran gama de
emociones y como ex mujer encarcelada
amiga de melissa y de su familia esto es
profundamente abrumador
lucio fue condenada en 2007 por matar de
una paliza a su hija de 2 años marbella
una de los 14 hijos que tuvo ella
siempre dijo que la menor falleció tras
caer por unas escaleras pero después de
cinco horas de interrogatorio y sin un
abogado confesó de manera coaccionada
ahora el tribunal de texas le ordenó a
las cortes del condado de cameron que
revisen el caso cinco de los doce
jurados que la condenaron reconocieron
que si hubiesen conocido todas las
pruebas no habrían pedido la pena de
muerte la fiscalía fue señalada de
ocultar documentos a favor de la mujer y
ninguno de sus hijos fue interrogado
porque mi lista está sentada en el
corredor de la muerte dónde está la
justicia dónde está el equidad ni
siquiera ha tenido tiempo de llorar a su
hija y sus hijos que la aman mucho están
luchando por ella
el caso de melisa lucio se conoció
cuando la cineasta sabrina ventas él
hizo un documental contando las
irregularidades y de ahí nos en project
la ong que trabaja para liberar a gente
inocente la ha respaldado además los
abogados de lúcio tienen nueva evidencia
de que la niña murió por un traumatismo
en la cabeza que concuerda con una caída
si el tribunal inferior las aprueba
podría exonerar a lúcio